Congress setting to return all set to
return rather in two weeks House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi is ratcheting a pressure on
lawmakers to act on gun violence the
country's most powerful Democrat said
just yesterday she would not take no for
an answer
after two mass shootings this month but
any push for reform faces opposition in
the republican-led Senate as Congress
struggles to address the issue we wanted
to talk to people who live with the
repercussions of mass shootings every
single day and it is tough
Stephanie Melendez's father was killed
in El Paso Texas earlier this month he
was shopping with his wife and
granddaughter nine years old he pushed
them both to safety
the Reverend Sharon richer lost her
mother and two cousins in the Charleston
Church massacre Richard Martinez's only
child Kris was killed during a rampage
in Isla Vista California and Nelda
Marquez greens little six year old
daughter on a grace was killed in the
Sandy Hook massacre in 2012 together
they all spoke of the seemingly
impossible task of moving on after
tragedy you go through periods of time
when you do feel you know the worst
thing that's ever happened to me it's
already happened to me but at the same
time I'm never gonna recover it you do
know I don't want to get over it i Kris
was our only child
getting over it would seem to me to be a
betrayal of my son's memory and I don't
want to get over it how do you go on if
you don't get over it I feel like I have
an obligation as a parent to my son and
that's the work that I do to try to stop
gun violence you said Sharon before we
got started now all the shootings are
ranked in categories what do you mean so
you have the hate crime category you
have the church category you have the
school category bottom line is dead as a
category people say it's about second
Amendment rights the right to bear arms
I have a right to see my daughter
enter eighth grade this fall and I don't
get to do that and I am grossly as a
mental health professional offended by
the words of our president and members
of Congress linking mental
this to mass shootings you don't see it
as a mental health issue the vast
majority of people who are mentally ill
are not violent by a long shot
most of the gun violence that we see on
a daily basis is related more to
domestic violence and misogyny one thing
that isn't talked about a lot is
suicides families who've lost a loved
one to suicide suffer the same grief
that we do have any of you ever thought
about suicide after this yes yes I would
say in the early days it was very dark
and I hoped by me saying yes others can
be encouraged by hearing it and asked
for help they need it was like I died
Chris was everything to me he was the
center of my life I think the reason why
suicide doesn't really consider Chris
wouldn't want that you know I'm living
from I'm all that's left of my son's
memory I'm keeping him alive
by being alive you know that's that's
really what it is I want to be with her
oh yeah
and I would if I could I would just say
I'm so sorry you know I'm so sorry you
didn't get what you deserved but I'll
stay here for the work that needs to be
done but I just want to be with her I so
feel that no but when you say I just
want to be with her I just wanted I just
want to be with her I have this
beautiful brown skin curly haired
singing daughter and I woke up one
morning and I didn't have her we have to
think about the people who were the
shooters in all of these cases they were
young white men in their 20s we don't
like to talk about race in a lot of
these mass shooting situations but I
think it's an important conversation to
have but Sandy Hook wasn't a race wasn't
a race it wasn't but it permeates
everything because I'll tell you an
interesting conversation my husband said
to me shortly after the shooting and he
goes you know I've spent my whole life
as a black man in America trying to
convey that I'm a safe person especially
in white environments
I look people in the eye I make sure not
to take up too much space because I'm a
six foot six inch 300-pound black man
yep a white person boy killed my
daughter and I'm not allowed to look at
him or look at others in that way right
I'm supposed to give a grace that I have
never been given as a black man in
America however I will I wish people
would give that to us and I sat in the
passenger seat and I just cried with him
Emmett Till's mother allowed people to
see what had been done to her son's body
and that changed the game in the civil
rights movement where are you all in
people seeing the damage that is caused
when your child your father your loved
one is shot Matt we need to see you
think that you can see they don't people
are visual learners people need to see
the devastation I think it's a fair
question I think it's an important one
to discuss I thought how many times was
on a shot many I mean many would you
have wanted us to see that absolutely
not
if this beautiful six-year-old baby her
living picture her voice her affect
everything about her alive didn't change
you her photo dead wouldn't change you
either I see if gun violence in America
does not make your heart hurt makes your
soul cry you can't feel that then you
can't feel anything your life is is
ordinary and and everything is in place
and then in a moment your world changes
I live in El Paso which has been named
it one of the safest cities all I know
is that my dad went and took my daughter
shopping for clothes and the next minute
he was gone you feel like you're in a
state of shock I think he would recall
shark mm-hmm in the beginning it was a
fog and you couldn't see clear but you
learn to navigate day by
one day might be a good day another day
I don't want to get out the bed and
still yes still there were years later I
can't call my mom's and ask her how do
you cook gumbo to go to Charleston now
is very difficult for me
she mentioned like picking up the phone
there's times I still pick up my phone
right I called my dad and I can't it is
not fair to create this permanent
underclass of people who have to do this
in addition to didn't you say you have
to go back to work next week are you
thinking Stephanie I have to get back to
living my life for my daughter for my
kids you know she's been through so much
she was there she was there and I need
to show her that the world doesn't stop
what would you all say to that she's
saying I have to make life normal again
I have to get back to work I would
advise sucks that's the first thing I'm
going to say and I'm answering because
Gail asked me be gentle with yourself
and honor the everyday but I do think
there's a encouragement of El Paso
strong Dayton strong well how do you
feel about that I mean I know it's
support but it's like a reminder that
this happened it's a reminder every day
yeah in the beginning it felt somewhat
comforting oh they haven't forgotten but
I think eventually people do move on and
the bumper stickers fade it is really
really wonderful to cheer El Paso strong
or Sandy Hook strong but it is even more
helpful to us if that came with a
commitment to lift us up forever because
we're not just grieving year one I will
grieve honor until the day I die
were you all on the issue of forgiveness
for the shooter my sister was the first
one to say I forgive you on the TV and I
started screaming and hollering like 48
hours and you're talking about
forgiveness
they took me almost a year even being a
reverend so you have you have forgiven I
have now why in order to get all of that
anger and rage I had to get to a point
in understanding what I really believed
in my fate and to be able to be free
where are you Richard do you think
you're capable of forgiving him no no no
but were you on forgiveness I just don't
understand why it's a narrative we
quickly go to after shooting so I'm glad
you're asking the question because now
other people can learn I saw at a new
town all of a sudden the forgiveness
families were in one bucket and those
were the the wise families and then the
ones who were like no why should I have
to forgive them we're seen as another
and they were asking that of Sandy Hook
families 24 hours later 48 hours later
and I'm like wait when did this become
my responsibility to absolve the person
who and to absolve it because I feel
like it's another way to let folks off
the hook I listened to a woman talking
about her experience in Las Vegas I'm a
veteran I served during the Vietnam era
and when this woman was talking to me
about the experience of what it was like
to be there at that concert Las Vegas it
reminded me of simulated combat we were
given the option of visiting the
classroom and one of the questions I
asked was where's the toilet and the
answer to that was we removed anything
that had been destroyed by gun violence
so if an industrial toilet was destroyed
by the firepower because you're thinking
imagine what it did to the children we
cannot as a nation say that is OK
because I didn't sign a six-year-old up
for war I signed her up for first grade
this is not our kids died because we
were negligent we have to address the
injustice that we are visiting on
American families it's like a hell's
lottery where if you lose today you lose
today and that's not okay
it's a health lottery Melba says that
we're all playing you know and it could
affect any of us any of us in this room
anybody was listening to this at any
time and one of the reasons why we
wanted to do this story is because I
feel that we're becoming too
sensitized Steve Hartman who does
beautiful pieces for us here at CBS
I've seen many stories and after one
shooting he said we mourn prey repeat
mourn prey repeat and I've never
forgotten those words I just want us to
see that behind all of these stories as
we all know there are people living
lives and people's lives were grossly
affected for the rest of their lives
woven into their family stories and I
can't I really want to hear it you can't
unhear it and I can't stop thinking
about it